well I mean come on III just look at it
like we're now a two and six football
team and we're like afraid to go for it
in a two-minute drill you know like who
cares if you give the ball back to the
guys with a minute forty seconds left
they obviously got the field goal anyway
and once again we're a two and six
football team and it just feels like
we're kind of afraid to lose a game it's
third and five at the end of the game
you know it's who cares that they have a
timeout there at the end or not you know
getting in field goal range isn't that
tough alright you know see yours putting
your defense in these bad situations and
I just felt like what do we have to lose
like why can't we be aggressive in some
of these situations that's kind of how I
feel about a lot of the game today
Joe Flacco if you're watching on TV he
kind of bites his lip like should I have
said all of that could you imagine what
we'd be saying today if Aaron Rodgers
went off like that and boy that way we'd
be talking about yeah you would my
goodness it would be like you just Pro
Football Talk the whole front page would
be 10 different Aaron Rodgers stories no
but here's the thing the Broncos are 2 &
6 nobody expected them to be any good
and I think Joe Flacco is sick of
getting blamed for how bad this team is
troy aikman went all-in on him 11 days
ago when the Broncos were lifeless
offensively and Troy Aikman called it
like he saw it you know Joe Flacco is
Joe cool when everything is going well
but that demeanor comes off as I don't
give a crap when you're losing that's
the point I think that's a that is he's
CEO under he's one of those guys where
he'd go man when things aren't good like
where was that fire during the game why
didn't you cut somebody out in the
sidelines in the third quarter or
something like that that's where I'd
question you know and listen I
understand maybe he wants to be more
aggressive I also understand their
offense is not good and it's not all
about Joe Flacco he's certainly not
anything special either at this point of
his career but their offense is not
anything special either so we need to
take that into account
so yeah the struggles aren't all about
him but yes he's not the kind of guy
that seems to take the lead or the reins
to go hey let's snap out of this funk
and then okay when your offense is not
that good and you're not playing that
good on top of that I don't think this
is the time you come out and make that
kind of call you know and I understand
you wanted to be aggressive but you gave
the Colts the ball
Oh at the 11-yard line and you have a
really good defense and Von Miller was
almost sacked for his safety and Jacobi
burr said got out and made a play so it
wasn't like a stupid decision by Vic
Fangio I just don't know about the
timing of these kind of comments by Joe
Flacco I guess that's what I'm
questioning well and I think he is
irritated that he's getting the blame
for a team that is two and six it's not
going as well as he thought when he
signed and they traded Emmanuel Sanders
last week which makes it harder for Joe
Flacco to do what he's trying to do and
it just feels like it's falling apart
you know I was looking around at some of
the rosters it's not like there's a
contending team out there that needs a
quarterback right now and I don't know
that a contending team would want Joe
Flacco right but you know some of these
guys as they get close to the trade
deadline and they know that window is
closing for good on possibly escaping a
bad situation I think that could add to
the manifestation of the frustration
because he's stuck now he's going
nowhere the rest of the year except
maybe the bench when draw comes right
right I mean that's what we're getting
dangerously close to now and that's
where probably he's a little worried as
well because yeah they did draft a guy
Andrew Luck who a lot of people thought
was a first-round type town they drafted
him in the second round and yes another
loss or - you're gonna go okay this one
looks like it's over for us in this
season and they might want to go see
what drew Locke has or get him some reps
and get him some game reps so he can
kind of hit the ground running next year
if they want to hand the reins over to
him to take over it's the starting
quarterback yeah the Broncos have had
two straight losing seasons and they are
three loss and they've got a turn it
could be five and three that's the thing
and I think that's why Flacco is upset
it's not all his fault there's plenty of
blame to go around but he's the one who
finds himself bearing the brunt of it
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports